I want to invent something I want to I
want to start a I want to start a
company I want to do something that has
maybe nothing to do with music I want I
don't have to like wake up in the
morning like remember that all right
today I got to remember to be this guy
or girl else someone's gonna catch on to
the fact that I'm not really me it's me
man you got to go to New York and make
it happen
well you don't think that's dead now do
it the way the weekend did it do it the
way partynextdoor did it do it the way I
did it you know do it from where you're
at the motivation what you talked em
with believe nation
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and make a difference
using it so let's get your motivation to
attend and get you believing in you grab
a snack and chew on today's lessons from
a man who was bullied as a child for his
racial and religious backgrounds to
dropping out of high school so he can
become an actor to now becoming one of
the best-selling rappers of all time
he's Drake and here's my take on his top
ten rules of success volume 2 enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be a great storyteller
[Applause]
[Music]
brat music has always been about
storytelling I've never seen the sense
in crafting a story that isn't my own
just rapping is not really that
impressive amount
it just has to be more that you have to
be a multi Lari artist
my father was like if you really want to
shop the world just sing a rap and I was
like you're crazy this is like the worst
idea possible rule number two
have a business mindset you said you
wanted to have 25 million dollars by the
time you're 25 you did that you know you
said you want 250 million by the time
you're 29
I mean this is given the modest way you
grew up what does money mean to you well
I think less than a dollar value it's
just more about the idea of growth and
business business mindset - you know 25
million at the time seemed crazy to me
but when you start becoming a headlining
touring act and you know brands want to
get involved with you and you can go do
private events and whatnot
it's you know you're capable of making
it and now I wanna you know for sure
obviously keep touring keep making music
but now I see that there's other ways
you know as far as like you know this
global ambassador thing as far as maybe
starting I want to invent something I
want to I want to start a I want to
start a company I want to do something
that has maybe nothing to do with music
I want rule number three just be you
there's a certain like - niceness about
you that I feel oh do you feel like that
about yourself or that the perception of
you is that's the People's Champ man I
just let the people talk for me I don't
really I don't really um get up here and
just like I don't have to tell you
necessarily like all the things that I
want you to know I'd like for you to
figure it out I don't I don't come up
here with like a message or a motive you
know I just like I just put my
everything into the music and I want the
people to tell everybody that it's good
not me I'm not trying to come up here
and sell you on the fact that I'm the
man you're a rapper you're supposed to
be yeah but I'm a new breed of rapper
you know sure I am I am I'm like
actually like a real person I'm not like
up here oh I don't have to like wake up
in the morning like remember all right
today I got to remember to be this guy
or care else someone's gonna catch on to
the fact that I'm not really me yeah
it's me man I get to be me rule number
four do things your way what was the
response you get as a Canadian
black Jewish rapper trying to get
attention in the u.s. I think that
details of my my like background kind of
came afterwards I think what caught
first was the music and I think what
became almost more appealing was like
this is the guy that I remember those
moments from people like wait wait this
guy is this guy like people really you
know drawing the the connection and I
always say I wouldn't have it any other
way men I wouldn't have it any other way
because I I truly don't know if I'd be
here if I didn't have so much to
potentially overcome as some people may
look at it I mean you don't look at it
that way not really because you know I'm
from Toronto I'm from a place where it's
a true mosaic you know there's weird to
me the most open-minded place you can
possibly find yourself so I don't ever
look at it as that you know but there
are other places that you go where it's
just not so it's it's not that simple
you know and yeah I never looked at it
as overcoming anything I was just like
man I just got to be a good rapper but
you know to a lot of other people
they're like wait wait wait let your
Canadian your Jewish and your half but
you know it's just like mind-blowing
things to them but like I said yeah I
don't think that you know it wasn't like
all my mixtape cover just said like the
new Canadian half black Jewish that I do
it wasn't like advertised okay
people had to go kind of find out about
me and I think when they did it made the
story even more interesting I like I
said I wouldn't want that to change
you rule number five push as far as you
can why do you care so much about
success have you figured that up I'm
just addicted to it I just I I think
that I've sacrificed so much for it
already and dedicated so much at my time
that I have to push it as far as I
possibly can because I've given up a lot
of years as far as maybe like nurturing
like personal relationships go and you
know trying to build things like a
family or a relationship or I don't I
don't like I don't do any of that I just
kind of work so with that being said and
how do you feel about that I'm okay with
that no at this point in my life I'm
okay with that
I think it's a great age to be doing
that you know I think maybe in ten years
if I'm still in that mindset I might
have to like come sit back down with you
and be like yeah we got everything this
is a different conversation tonight rule
number six be honest is the Drake in the
in in the lyrics always that you yeah
100% always me there's no I don't really
exaggerate it's not an amped-up
character it's not not just how I feel
inside you know of course my mind my
feelings inside are always gonna be
amped up you know like I said I was
taught by a phenomenal woman my mother
how to conduct myself on a day-to-day
basis so the person that you meet is
always or I mean hopefully I'm always
gonna be somebody who's you know a
pleasant to deal with rule number seven
my personal favorite changed the way you
think
Toronto's the reason I do this all I did
was find a way to make people proud of
our city artists from our city their
whole objective was to get power so I
just had to flip that way of thinking
these guys men that like you got to go
to New York and make it happen well you
don't think that's dead now do it the
way the weekend did it do it the way
partynextdoor did it do it the way I did
it you know do it from where you're at
rule number eight strive for greatness
say about this particular gentleman from
Toronto Kardinal Offishall Yale mall man
well I mean one of my fondest memories
is walking walking through York Dale
mall right by the bay and the old old
Harry Rose's you got to know the old
Harry Rosen to know about that but
turning the corner and seeing you know
seeing this guy standing like what
looked like at the time like 75 wearing
like a fur Kangol and like a D dis track
suit and and I remember just he was the
biggest rapper in the city and I
remember I was walking in the mall I
don't remember exactly who I was with
but I turned to the person I was with
and I said I'm gonna be bigger than that
guy one day and that was my memory of
careful what you wish for it was a
moment but at the same time you know he
was he was he was to me larger than life
in that mall you know so it was it
wasn't like an offensive thing it was
something to strive for you know I
wanted to be bigger than that because
you know prior to that we had seen him
come out at like rock the caravan and
with jay-z and he had songs ringing off
across the world so it was it was he was
our guy you know he was the first one to
really be like a star boy from out here
so rule number nine find your path
definitely when I started to get into my
teens is when I started to take an
interest in becoming a musician you know
I remember initially I was like thinking
of being a DJ you know I went to
the record and bought like some
turntables and some records and you know
I thought that would be kind of like
maybe a moment for me and that was maybe
like at the beginning very beginning of
high school you know but I was always
making music you know I was always had
you know instrumentals and was always
kind of rapping rapping over these beats
that I could find I think off the time
you would have to get your handler
instrumentals off like Napster so you
know I was I was I was always interested
in making the music and rule number 10
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is have fun
[Applause]
[Music]
I swear my only friend friend friend
friend friends you know how good my
London accent is when you were going
these guys came off your dog you know
what it is dog pick up yourself bro you
don't know Drizzy Drake dog it's crazy
right he's not a bad sounding dog you
know what it is but they talk like they
talk like they want to shoot you in your
face yeah that's like yo dog you know
what is your demand dog you don't mind
your legend dog right exactly thing
Craig did hosting the ESPYs last night
he's kind of an outstanding guy he says
that he came from the bottom which most
likely he didn't know what would you say
to Drake if Jake was here right now
Drake would see right now if Jake was
here right now uh probably freaked out
and asked them if I could get a picture
with really are you Drake man definitely
I should pick a Drake song right now
let's hear it right up ahh trophies
say you give me a little bit give me a
taste I want a sample I want a sample
platter okay uh trophies um a my lot of
cus sure Oh [ __ ] I go just a [ __ ] I go
to sleep with a suitcase
oh my god
[Applause]
you
now I've got two really special Drake
bonus clips on how to express yourself
fully and how to make it happen but
before that I want to know what did you
learn from this video what was the
single most important lesson that you
were going to apply to your life for
your business somehow leave it down the
comments below when you write it down
it's much more likely that you will take
action on it so leave it in the comments
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love see you soon and
enjoy the bonus clips
you're such an interesting guy because
there's like there's a paradox that
emerges when it comes to you that the
two personalities of Drake right there's
this confident guy who has bravado who
wants to win who is number one and wants
to be number one and and carries himself
with that kind of confidence and then
there's the vulnerable emotive guy who
almost converge on insecure at times do
you see that paradox in yourself yeah I
I think that I'm just a human being that
that's willing to show you that I'm
human you know I don't know if it's a
paradox or if it's like some rare
character trait is just that a lot of
people will only show you the confidence
side especially in music because the
vulnerable side is like I would like
they don't want to go there you know I'm
okay with going there I that that to me
is supreme confidence the fact that I
could express you know the issues that
I'm having with family with women or
with self you know the fact that I the
fact that I can express that is to me
the ultimate confidence I'm not worried
about these other rappers
I'm not competing with those guys I
already know their hand I know their
move
I study everything I'm worried about the
kid
that's sitting in his house that wants
to be better than me and all those guys
that's who I'm competing
that's how I tried to keep pushing this
pool just to let that kid know that I'm
mad like I already just do this tonight
or what ma'am
straight go by the name of trizzie Drake
if you have the music that's all it
takes present it to the world and the
world will tell you if it's worth your
time enough I'm Drake
obey your thirst long yeah the most
important work ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you Apple that would be
like a little beacon pay believe nation
if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]